hey hi friends my name is abishek rashan
and welcome to my channel engineer
abishek rashan so friends today I going
to discuss 100 Linux basic commands
whether you are a IT professional or non
IT professional or whether you are a
college goinging student or a working
professional my friends everybody needs
these 100 Linux basic commands why
whether you are Android User Mac User
Windows user or or even if you are
preparing for competitive exam also
these Linux 100 basic command is
definitely going to help you out so let
me tell you what all these 100 Linux
basic commands so so friends let's start
the session without wasting our time
because time is money for us and Friends
those who are new to this Channel please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
the channel and press the Bell icon so
so let's get started First Command my
friend right so what is the First
Command the first command is nothing but
that is called PWD PWD is nothing but
this is stands for present working
direcory means it is showing that where
exactly you are what is your present
working directory if I going to where
okay if I'm doing PWD it will show you
slw over here so my present working
directory is where so the next command
is LS command Okay so LS command is
nothing but it's called listing means if
you want to see the files okay inside a
directory okay then you can use LS
command wherever you if you want to list
all the files or directory then you can
use LS command CD command CD command is
stands for change directory if you want
to move from one place to other place
from One Directory to other directory
suppose if I want to move from here okay
uh from where directory to or suppose
you are already in SL if you do PWD
present working directory is SL spun log
is there right underscore logs is there
so if I want to move it from where you
want to go to where directory just do a
and then the PWD you are inside slw
directory next command is mkd if you
want to create a directory okay I want
to create a directory called elk okay so
here I'm creating a directory called elk
and if I do LL okay so you will come to
know that elk is created how I come to
know it is a directory d stands for
directory and these all are files
because if nothing is mention this is a
regular file my friend okay moving on to
the next command my friend that is rmd
that is removing a directory if you want
to remove a directory just do a rmd
suppose if I want to remove this elk
directory enter now if I do LL so you'll
come to know there is no elk directory
over here moving on to the next command
my friend that is touch command if you
want to create a empty file again
repeating my sentence if you want to
create a empty file so then you can use
a touch command suppose here I'm
creating a file uh. txt okay or if I I
can make it as a file 1.txt okay Enter
so it's going to create a file with a
zero KB here you can see that this
stands for zero means there is no data
inside this file one.txt is there uh
moving on to the next command that is RM
command my friend RM command stands for
removing a file okay if you want to
remove a file which file just now we
created this file file 1.txt and enter
so remember you need to give your option
means whether you want to delete this
file or not just give y so it's going to
delete moving on to the next command my
friend uh the command is called uh CP
command if you want to copy a file okay
so suppose here we have a log file right
that is plun do log okay so I am I want
to copy this file okay to a different
location so how you are going to to do
that one so then suppose you I want to
copy this file inside uh uh anywhere you
just take it under where okay so you can
copy and you can copy the same file with
a different name okay suppose instead of
this is pl. log I am going to make it as
a elk dolog you are creating a duplicate
copy of this file means you are copying
this file to a different location with a
different name
and the data will be also intact the
data will be also same just enter and if
you go slw and then log friend just go
to CD /w and do a l over
here
so here you can see elk. log is there or
if you want to make it uh easy just do a
LS hyphen ltrs so the latest you can see
bottom and you can see the size is also
same moving on to the next command
suppose I want to rename this file or if
I want to move this file okay uh there
are two things you can do with the MV
command move command either you can move
this file from one location to other
location or if you want to rename a file
also then you can use MV let me show you
okay so uh I want to move this file elk.
log where you want to move again I want
to move it to isun do logs directly now
you go where you go uh just go to spun
dolog and just do a l over there so here
you can see it's came back to elk. log
over there now I want to rename also
then also you can use MB command Okay so
instead of elk. log I want to rename it
to kibana okay kibana do
log right so enter now if you do L
instead of elk dolog it's rename to
Kiana dolog you can understand from this
101 also okay moving on to the next
command my friend uh that is cat command
if you want to see the detail inside a
file then you can I do cat plunk so cat
command is not only used to see the
detail of a file cat command can be also
used to see to append a data inside this
file cat command also is used to create
a new file also next command is more
more or less Command right so more or
less command is what so let me show you
let me go to where logs directory there
is directory called where logs directory
and if I do LS hyen LTR so here there is
a log called messages okay so more with
the more if you want to see the data of
a file page wise okay then you can use M
then you can use more command suppose
I'm using more more and I am giving this
one so here you can see this is the data
and if you want to see this one page
wise enter you will be just do enter
okay so it will show you the data of a
file page wise so what will list list
will also do the same uh let's come out
of it
okay so let's come out of it and instead
of this I'm going to use less command
and same message so here you can see you
can so more or less will be same only
next command is your head command see if
you want to see top 10 lines of a file
okay then you can use head command you
can use that is up to you but by default
it's going to show you top 10 lines if I
use head okay and if I use message enter
so by default it's going to show you
only 10 lines how it's going to show you
only 10 lines let me show you I am going
to run in with this command with WC c
hyen l WC hyphen L is nothing but this
is called word count and your listing
enter how many lines it is telling only
10 lines so by default remember these
are interview question also so by
default head command is going to show
you 10 lines top 10 lines so what is the
purpose of tell command so tell command
is going to show
you bottom 10 lines of a file okay from
bottom not from Top from bottom so same
thing I going to run it with the message
okay so here also I am able to see the
data of a file the bottom 10 lines of a
file but from bottom and this is also 10
lines also you can prove it WC hyen l so
you can see this is also by default will
give 10 lines from the bottom of a page
or a file so friend next command is your
Nano command so mostly see uh in few of
the Linux flavors or distributions right
so uh some of the somewhere you'll be
able to use Nano editor and you can use
VI editor most of the places means more
than 500 distributions are available in
the market so all those distributions
you can use VI editor that is a like
common or a
generic so mostly you can use Nano also
but both are editor only I'll show you
so if you use VI suppose let me go to
cd/ plank okay logs here so uh just do a
l over here so so if suppose if I want
to open this edit this file spang. log
so then I can use VI editor okay Enter
so here you can see just put a
insert and you can add a data next to it
enter right so I'm going to add a new
data inside this one instead of this I'm
going to add and just do a write and
quit colon write Escape colon write and
quit enter right so here you can see if
you do a tab and then just do a spun do
log so so you will come to know your uh
this data is this line is added to this
file right now then what Nano is doing
Nano is also do the same way but a
different uh editor that is just that is
just a editor like notepad you know
notepad++ is there windows we use right
same way here also in Linux we use Nano
editor and we use show you with the Nano
Nano command and you can give same plun
let me give this one only enter so here
you can see right and in this one if
suppose I have to add a new
line just copy and paste just do a seven
okay and what you need to do is control
and then enter that's it and just to
exit control X so now if I do again
cat you'll come to know see there is a
new line added to this one right so this
is how you can use VI editor and you can
use Nano editor so friends moving to the
next command that is your grape command
grape command is nothing but grape
command is going to give a specific
pattern of a file if you want to search
a specific pattern means a specific word
from a file then you can use your which
command then you can use grape command
grape command also it stands for uh
General regular expression my friend
okay so grap command let me show you
okay so grap and then suppose if I if I
want to see uh how many this is this
word is used in this particular file
right so just do a this okay
and from where from which file from
spung dolog so you can see here also
right it's coming in red color okay and
if you want to know how many times this
word is used in this particular file
same WC hyphen L you can use seven times
so this is how you can use grap command
so now what is the purpose of find
command find command is used to find a
file inside a Linux system whether that
file is anywhere okay if that file is in
SLB SL data or in SL temp SL Etc SL opt
in any directory you don't know where is
the exact location of that uh uh Splunk
do log how you are going to find so you
are going to use find command and where
in the topmost level you don't know
means that is the root directory the
topmost level root I'm talking about
that is not that r o o t root so means
this is the topmost level of your Linux
file system of a Linux machine of a
Linux okay uh system so friends here and
then you need to give name and then you
need to give
this spang. log okay just give enter
here you can see it's giving you the
exact location of Spun dolog I'll tell
you there is also one command which you
can use instead of uh because uh in
Industry we use these things so instead
of find command you can use locate
command also okay and uh just give us
plank. log so it will give you the same
Lo slun dolog under that spun dolog is
there right friends so friend now moving
on to the next command that is which
command so which command is what suppose
you want to know uh a particular command
for example I'm find command only I'm
talking about find command is executing
from where find command is executing
from SL bin SL USR /bin find command
friend next command is called who am
I I'm not telling you who am I I OB
rashan you also know okay but but who
Ami command is like that only so just
understand what is who Ami command you
will come to know so who Ami command is
going to give you which is the current
user through which you have logged into
your Linux machine now the next command
is called who command you will only come
to know what is who command is who
command is going to give you the
detailed user who is logged into this
system so here you can see it was a root
user you logged in then you logged in
through the terminal detail
TTY who and all is logged into this
system so friends let's move on to the
next command that is PS command PS
command is used to see the running
application or you can say the running
processes of a Linux machine let me use
but PS command if you give like this
it's not going to give you all the all
the processes okay so if you want to see
what all processes is running for this
machine okay for this Linux machine you
can use PS hyphen EF and if you want to
grip a specific process so you can use
suppose Java is running spun is running
elk is running right anything then you
need to grab that particular okay you
need to grab that particular uh process
name so here you can see there is no
Java process is running okay command is
my friend that is top command what is
top command stands for top command is
going to give you the
complete process
detail of your Linux operating system
means what means how many users have
been logged in what is the load average
of this system for last 5 minutes 10
minutes and 15 minutes what is the CPU
utilization what is the memory
utilization what is the swap utilization
from what is the P ID of a process
process ID which user is logged in what
is the priority what is the nice value
see what is the CPU utilization for that
particular Pro process what is the
memory utilization of that particular
process how uh what is the percentage of
ideal of your particular CPU will be
there right every detail if you want to
know then you can use top command so
friends let's move on to the command
called CH mod okay CH mod is stands for
if you want to
modify okay of a file
permission so then you can use CH mod
modification of your file how you are
going to do do this one let me go to
spung dolog right and just do a ll so
here you can see file permission what is
the permission of this file so the file
permission is read right read read means
what this is uh I numerically if you
want to make it uh then you can
calculate this one how so for read and
write this will be uh your six okay and
then read will be four means read will
be uh uh uh 644 okay the permission of
this particular file is
644 so if you want to change the
permission of this file from 644 to Tri
7 so you'll understand okay so uh just
do a CH mod and I'm going to change this
file this Kiana dolog okay tople 7 I'm
going to give full permission to this
file enter so if if you do LL you will
come to know read write execute read
write execute read write
execute how I calculated
644 see read stands for four write
stands for here don't not that right
okay W so read write and X execute so 4
2 and 1 again 4 2 and 1 again 4 2 and 1
so here 4 and 2 six again four again
four 6 4 4 4 and if I want to change it
to again back to 644 you'll see the
magic okay CH mod okay the permission of
this file again I'm doing 644 okay and
I'm giving the same logs over here enter
and just do LL over here so it's become
the same permission what it was there
before now the next command is CH own
that is ownership if you want to change
the ownership permission of a file then
you can use CH own means ownership means
what if suppose this is file is who owns
this file root Only spang. log LL right
and here now I'll change this permission
to what to same okay ownership CH own
ownership of this file colon again and
then what I'm going to do over here is
I'm going to give the file name what is
that file name my friend Kiana dolog now
you'll see the ownership is changed
command is ch grp ch grp stands for you
if you want to change the group
permission see here ownership means who
is the owner so this is the first one is
stands for here only you'll come to know
uh I'll show you okay so uh let me
change this one you'll come to know what
I'm talking about first so uh This is er
colon and root
okay and give this
k.l just do like this so you can see who
is the owner of this file the owner of
this file is your engineer a oan one but
still the group permission is with root
user but so you want to change the group
permission or group file permission of
this particular user of this particular
file then what you you are going to use
is
chgrp okay and just instead of root I'm
going to make it as a e a ran one only
and simply just give this one enter now
see this is stands for your group
permission friends uh moving on to the
next command that is DF command so you
will come to know what is DF command
stands for DF command stands for dis
free if you want to see the detail
information of your file system means
your file system is suppose d/ sda3 is
so how much is used okay how much is
available where it is mounted the dis
use means how much DF stands for disc
free so if you do uh DF H also you will
come to know in readable so you can
understand how much just suppose here 6
GB is used 12 GB is available where it
is mounted on topmost level right and
what is is the file system is used over
here okay this is the partition the file
system is it's formatted with okay and
what is then du du stands for disk uses
if you want to see how much is a file
consumes or a space suppose if I go to
cd/ plunk log you want to see the sizes
of file inside Splunk log then just do
duyen s
okay sorry do hen sh and then you need
to give Star my friend because here so
you will come to know suppose Kiana log
is there so that is of 4kb rest all is
empty files only spun do log is
4kb okay guys you are understanding my
point this is how you can use DF command
and du command uh moving on to the next
command that is called free Command with
the help of free Command you'll come to
know how much the memory is utiliz ized
by this particular Linux machine okay
let me clear this one so free okay if I
run this simply you'll get confused so
let me make it more readable free hyphen
M so you will come to know how much MB m
stands for MV if I do free hyph G so you
will come to know GB so you'll come to
know what is the difference between free
and free m and free G uh free hyph G
right so it's going to give you your
memory detail means your RAM detail
exact Ram detail and your swap memory
detail okay so friends let's move on to
the next command that is your tar
command so uh let's go to again is plunk
log just do a let's clear everything so
friends uh tar command is used to
Archive the files uh suppose here you
can see uh these are the files my friend
right so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to put all this file into a
single directory so I'm going to create
a directory called uh
mkd
plunk archive okay Enter so here uh if I
if you see here uh this is created now
I'm going to move all these file inside
this one okay so mainly tar command is
used to Archive a file or to compress a
file see actual size of this file could
be in GB also right suppose you have
ngbs of logs then in that that situation
you what you need to do is you need to
compress that file you suppose these
logs are in GBS and you you need to make
sure that you cannot delete also because
this is a data right so in that
situation let me move this all is plunk
right and star where and I want to move
it to inside this one okay so here you
can see all the files have been moved to
inside is plun right now just come out
of this one so so friends here you can
see uh now I'm going to Archive this
spunk archive means I am going to Tar
this file I'm going to compress the
directory how I'm going to do that one
so tar hyphen cvf okay that is compress
veros and F is stands for forcefully
okay and then you need to give dot tar
extension and from where from this only
enter so you can see now your directory
is do tar just do LL over here here you
can see isun doar is there right so this
directory you have archived it you have
compress it to doar so friends moving on
to the next command that is your gzip
command suppose if you want to zip this
file okay so just run the command called
Simple gzip command okay and just give
this log okay Enter now you can can see
this this particular log is compressed
to your log. ZZ if you want to reduce
the file size then you can use gzip and
if you want to unzip this one just run
called gunzip okay gunzip same is
opposite to this one okay and just enter
so here you will come to know now it's
unzip now okay so friends if you want to
zip that tar file means this archive
then you can use zip command so zip
command and uh just give this one
okay and uh dot GJ and from where you
are doing Enter so you can see it's zip
that one just do a ll over here so tar
do ZZ okay now I'm going to show you how
to unar this file okay to this archive
file so tar hyphen xvf enter and then
you need to give the Tar this one enter
so you can see now it is unar because
this directory is already available over
there so it's uh showing the same
friends moving on to the next command
that is WG command suppose if you want
to download something from the internet
okay then you can use what command then
you can use your WG command and uh this
is the download link I'm just wanted to
show you I'm just copy this link and I'm
directly coming to my puty now if I do W
get okay I give this URL going to
download you see it's downloaded now
okay and it's downloaded under spun
dolog here you can see the package. RPM
is downloaded over here right so friends
moving on to the next command that is
curl command so with the help of curl
command you can come to know a UR
whether a data is transferring through a
URL or not okay so whether that URL is
working or not so if I'm doing a curl
what is
www. Google
do com enter so you are able to see so
much of data this is just data right it
means it is working to
see right the server which you are
trying to reach is reachable or not okay
so if you want to see a server is
reachable or not or application is
reachable or not so uh mostly it will be
a server it's nothing to do with your
application so you are going to Ping
that one so how you you don't know the
IP normally IP is not a human rable so
what you are going to do over here is
you are just going to do a
ww.
google.com so you will be you are
getting the responses right means what
your Google server is reachable if you
want to see a server is reachable or not
you can use ping command so moving on to
the next command my friend that is if
have config so so by use of if config
command you can see the IP of your
server of your Linux machine so friends
moving on to the next command that is
SSH command so SSH is nothing but it's a
protocol to log from one server to other
server uh it's a basically a protocol
and it's uses 22 number code and if you
want to login just do a SSH okay and you
need to give that server suppose if you
and and the usern name also you need to
give suppose if I want to login as a
root user or a normal user also so if
you want to log in as a normal user uh
you can take the name of that normal
user over here suppose if I want to
login with
uhr a russan 2 okay so let me show you
uhr a Roan 2 at the rate of and the IP
of that server okay and what is the IP
of that server is 191 so it will ask you
whether you want to log in yes but this
time it's asking you the password okay
I'll tell you
why so you have logged into that server
how you come to know you have logged it
to you can see it's now earlier it was e
ngr a rtion one and even if I run the
command call if have config the IP is
Chang 191 right right so but this time
it's asking you the password but if you
want to make it to password less so for
that you need to generate a public and
private key so the public key has to be
deployed in This Server okay in your
target server and in the source server
you need to deploy your private key my
friend now if I want to copy any file
from one server to another server
suppose if I want to copy this file okay
Kiana dolog okay under T of that other
server ngr a Ran 2 then how I am going
to do the do that one so just do a SCP
give this file name over here and you
need to give same way only okay there is
no other way so for that you need to
give the username same way what we we
did with SSH so uh you need to give
the user name over here my friend just
take this
username okay at the rate of okay and uh
you need to give the IP of that server
what is the IP of that server my friend
so you can take it from here I'm just
changing over there
to 191 colon slash where you want to
copy under T so it's going to ask you
the
password but if you want to make it as a
pass so it's copyed right so you did a
SCP so uh please make sure uh ring
command is used suppose uh in between
when you are copying a file from one
location to other location means one
server to another server in between your
connection got disconnected okay by some
issue some Network glitch will be there
so in that scenario what will happen is
your file you need to copy from the
start only from where it left not from
where it left from starting only means
the data but in our syn what will happen
is the data suppose any glitch happened
or network disconnect disconnected okay
so it start copying from where it
left you're understanding my point my
friend right so this is the difference
between SCP and R sync so ryn command
you can go ahead and you can use it by
you yourself the syntax will be the
command will be r s y n c like this same
way you can use it it is your task okay
moving on to the next command that is
your pass WD command if you want to
change the the password of a user okay
then you can use pass WD command so
don't use pass WD command simply okay if
you run like pass WD so it's going to
change the password of that root user
please make sure if you are a root user
so don't do this mistake so what you
need to do is pass WD and you need to
give the
username okay so suppose uh let me check
what all are here C CC W okay so here
you can see this user is here okay so
you can create a different user also
okay so uh now I'm going to show you how
to create a user suppose if you have to
create a new user what is that user
subscriber
one okay Enter right so if I do c/
TC so you can see subscriber user is
created subscriber one user is created
but the password of this user is not set
so for that pass WD command is there you
need to give it like this enter it's
going to ask you the password just give
that password so password is changeed
successfully uh friend moving on to the
next command that if you want to delete
a user then you can use a call command
user Dell okay remember and there are
some options also which you can use
because see when you use directly user
Del command it's not going to delete the
home directory of that user so in that
situation you need to use hyphen R okay
so it's going to delete the home
directory of that user also so I have
created a user called subscriber one
enter okay so it's deleted that user is
deleted so same if you run this command
now there is no subscriber one user over
here now if you want to make any
modification for that users suppose here
you can see the username and uh the uh
these are nothing but the uid and the g
ID this is nothing but like uh from
where the user default shell is there
what is the comment over here so if you
want to make any modification the U ID
of that user or the G ID of that user
then you can use user mode command okay
and then hyphen C what comment I'm going
to do it over here you can give any any
anything like uh this is
uh test
user okay and just give this one under
ports okay and give the username over
here
enter now run the same command you'll be
able to see this comment is entered for
this particular user this is a test user
so this is how you can make any of this
whether you want to change the home
directory of this user you can use this
one uh whether you want to change the
uid of this user you can do this one
okay so you can make even default shell
you can change of this user with user
mod command you can do it my friend
friends moving on to the next command
that is group AD if you want to create a
group okay like user we have added right
so same way if you want to create a
group then you need to add called uh
group add command is there okay so
friends uh same like you are adding a
user same way you can add a group also
uh if you want to see where the group is
added so cat SL Etc uh group is the file
okay so here you can see the subscriber
one uh by default a group will be
created for the user so same one if I
want to create a uh directly group okay
so just run a command called group and
then add and then you need to like
suppose I'm uh creating a uh
YouTube underscore family okay so this
group is added how I come to know that
this group is created so here you can
see this is a secondary Group which I've
created and you can add this user
subscriber one to YouTube family also
like this that also you can uh do it so
same way also if you want to delete this
group so just do a
group and then tell okay and then you
need to give this group
name okay so now if you run the same
command that group is deleted from here
there is no group exist over here same
way if you want to make a modification
to the existing group that also you can
do it just run a command called group
mod and then you need to give a group
name over here so this is the way you
can do it my friend okay so friends
moving on to the next command that is
Pudo command Pudo command is St that
that is Pudo okay Pudo command stands
for Pudo can uh super user can do means
if you want to
execute a command as a root user then
you can use sudo command okay friend
moving on to the next command that is
command just now I have shown you if you
want to switch a user from one user to
other user suppose Su and I want to
switch it to a which user just now I
have created one user also subscriber
one subscriber one okay you have
switched to if you run a command called
who am I you'll come to know you are in
subscriber one exit so friends moving on
to the next command that is your date
command if you see I run a date command
it's going to give you the date of this
particular Linux machine and uh same way
Cal command you can run it will going to
give you the calender friends moving on
to the next command that is the host
name command host name command is
everybody should know if you run a host
name so see here because I have not set
a host name of my machine so normally
you will see a virtual machine has some
host name right so here you can see I
have not given a name to my server I can
set a host name okay so that even I can
make a for example host name and I'm
going to give uh my server
ww. TNG R
aoan
one.com enter okay now if I run a see uh
host name command so you can see it is
change now and uh so this is how you can
come to know what is the host name means
the name of that server okay so moving
on to the next command my friend that is
UN name command so this is very good
command normally uh ask in interview
also uh so if you run a uname command it
will show you what machine this is okay
so there are different options you can
use it with it's a Linux machine so it's
going to give you Linux and uh you name
hyph so it's going to give you the
complete architecture of this machine if
you want to see the kernel version also
you can come to know with the UN name if
you want to see different options you
can use it with you name and you can
check it's your task so un name command
is mostly going to give you details of
this op operating system normally moving
on to the next command my friend that is
Fisk command is there f disk okay f disk
hyphen L command is there so normally f
disk hyphen L command is used to see the
disk information of your Linux operating
system this is very important see here
you can see d/ SDA this is one of the
disk which is uh partition has been done
for this dis same way and same uh LSB l
l k command hyphen L is also used for
the same purpose so if you want to see
the uh information so if you want to see
the information of your disk okay or the
partition then you can use lsblk hyphen
l or you can use f disk hyph L command
both is so friends moving on to the next
command that is Mount command Mount
command is nothing but if you want to
mount for example let me show you uh DF
suppose if you want to mount a
particular partition okay to a directory
and why we are doing this one because
suppose uh you have created a partition
/d/ sda3 and you want to utilize that
partition means obviously you are going
to store a data right where you are
going to store your data inside your dis
like normally if you copy your hard disk
also right you are copying so same way
here also in Linux you have your disk or
a partition so how you are going to use
that one you need to mount suppose any
directory which you have created on top
on this friend uh first of all run the
command called df5 Edge over here and uh
you can see here uh uh there is
no so here you can see here also d/ sda3
is there but there is another partition
which I have created over here just run
a command called lsblk hyen Edge so
you'll come to know there is a d there
is a partition which I have already
created as DB1 in this different server
so now I'm going to use the mount
command to utilize this partition how
I'm going to do that one my friend so uh
just do a CD slash okay Len LTR here I'm
going to create a directory called
subscriber 2 okay so if I do LS hyphen
LTR then you can see it is here right
but I have not used uh utiliz that dis
okay so I'm going to use a command
called Mount okay and what I'm going to
do here I'm going to mount on/
sdb sdb one where you want to mount you
want to mount on subscriber
two now run DF and H command see it's
mounted right so this is the use of
Mount command okay now if you have to
unmount there is also called ount
command just do a ount command okay and
and then you just give subscriber to
enter now if you do df5 H it's gone
right so uh moving on to the next
command my friend that is uh kill all
command is there with the help of kill
all command you can
terminate uh the process with the
process name so friends moving on to the
next command uh the command is called uh
this command is very important so please
don't forgot this command so it's going
to give you uh all your network
statistic suppose which Port is
listening or which Port is not listening
you can use the option called a andp
okay and pipe and then you can grip also
suppose any of this port for a
particular Port uh you wanted to know
that whether it's listening or not okay
it's connected or not then you can use
net stat net setat mainly stands for
Network statistic okay to see a port is
listening or not right so next moving on
to the next command my friend that is LS
PCI so LS PCI command is going to give
you the list of PCI devices okay so same
way LS
USB command is there so you'll come to
know which all USB devices is connected
so as you can see a mouse is connected
uh Root Hub is connected like that so
all the details which all us USB is
connected to this uh particular virtual
machine my friend okay okay friends
let's move on to the next command that
is mkfs command so here mkfs command is
like if you want to format a file system
guys then you can use mkfs command you
can see MK if you run a make file system
uh it stands for mkfs okay if I do so
you can uh format a file system with
EXT2 ext3 or ext4 so suppose you have a
dis okay let me show you if I run a
command called
lsblk okay Enter so here you can see
this is a disk SDC and uh this is the
partition which I have already done sdc1
so if I have to format because to use to
utilize a disk okay first what you need
to do is uh you need to format that disk
like in Windows like in pen drive you
can uh you do a format of NTFS or a fat
file system right same way Linux also
you need to use a dis then you need to
format that one so the just run make
file system MK FS okay and I'm going to
format this with ext4 and which file
system and which partition SL da SL
sdc1 okay so
enter so here you can see now this
particular partition is formatted with
mkfs okay so friends moving on to the
next command that is FSC fsck stands for
file system check so it's going to check
the Integrity of a file system means
what means suppose your file system got
corrupted then how you going to make
sure the file system is error free right
when your Linux system reboots okay at
that time normally what happened is some
of the file system get corrupted so your
Lin system will not come up this is that
reason the Linux system will not come up
it will be either in hung or it will not
in come up in that situation you need to
run the command called FS
CK where where your partition is mounted
suppose SL D just now you have seen SD
C1 and just run this command so here you
can see clearly it's telling that this
particular is this particular d/ sd1 is
clean means there is no error free so if
error will be there it will be 0 1 2 3
like that it will be there and you can
repair all repair also that one so
friends let's move on to the next
command that is rpm hyph IVs
if you have to install the package okay
so this is nothing but radad package
manager and I stands for install v
stands for ver H stands for hash format
so if you want to install any package or
any application in your Linux operating
system then you can use RPM hyon ibh
command okay so let me show you I'm
going to install vsftpd over here so you
can see vsftpd is installed and the next
command is if you want to know that
whether a package is installed or not
just run a command called RPM hyphen QA
and just give a vs
ftpd okay so it's going to give you
output means this package is installed
okay and so friend if you want to
uninstall the package so then what you
need to do RPM hyphen e
vsftpd enter so it's going to uninstall
the package if you run the same command
uh RPM hen QA whether the package is
installed or not it's not going to give
you any output so friend the next
command is how to start a service so
just now you have seen we have installed
vspd so now we are going to start vsftpd
service so for that you can run a
command called system CTL start vsftpd
and how we can come to know the next
command is called my friend that is to
check whether vssf tpd service is
running or not so here you can see
clearly vspd service is running and it's
active Okay and now if you have to stop
this service then you can run the
command system CTL stop vsftpd okay so
friend this is how uh we can start a
service stop a service and we can come
to know the status of a service okay
friends moving on to the next command
that is history command so if you run a
history command so you'll come to know
what all commands you have executed in
the current session till now remember
once you have disconnected this session
you will not get all this one so please
make sure if you want to know what all
commands you have executed you need to
run history command so friends moving on
to the next command that is awk command
that is a command also we can say so if
you want to know what is a a command you
can just do a a and manual so you'll
come to know what is off command off
command is mostly you can say it's a
text processing language and it's used
to see from a file if you want to filter
something if you want to get any data
from a file okay if you want to process
a file okay if you want any sort of a
data from a file you can use a command
so let me show you how we can use a
command it's very important so here you
can see uh I have a file called new do
txt okay so I'm going to run a command
let me show you what is there in new.
txt so in new. txt there are uh almost I
can say five names are there and
everybody has their age over here
so suppose if I want a list of people
who is having 30 years or older than
that okay then how I am going to get
this data and how I'm going to fetch the
data from this text or from this text
file okay so friends for that you need
to run this a command and then dollar to
greater than equal to 30 print and then
you need to give this file name so here
you will come to know see Bob is and
David is 35 so who is having 30 and
older than 30 you are getting that data
so this is how you can use a command the
next command is your uh S command Set uh
set command is nothing but s you can say
this is SED SED is nothing but it's a
stream editor so if you want to search a
word and you want to replace that word
with that searchable word let me show
you how we can do this one uh so we have
a file called uh Kiana so what is there
inside this one so here you can see this
is used almost uh six times okay so I
want to replace this this with my okay
then how I'm going to do that one with
the S set command and you need to use
single codes and then you need to give s
yeah and the word which you are
searching okay what word you are
searching this one and then again which
what which word you want to rep place
with this one so you are giving this one
my and you need to give G over here and
finally you need to give the file name
over here enter so are you able to see I
am able to replace this with my so this
is how you can use set command that is
so friends let's move on to the next
command that is sort command sort
command is mostly used to ascending and
descending order of a file so here you
can see this is a file Kiana dolog and
if if I have to make this file in a
proper order then we can use sort
command just let me show you so if I use
a sort command and then I run this one
so here you can see it's giving me the
output with 1 2 3 4 5 6 but the actual
data of this file is in in some random
order so friends the next command is
called unique command unique command as
the name clearly stated that that un n
IQ okay with the with this one you can
remove the duplicates so first let me
show you the cat I'm going to show you
this this what is there in the Kiana
dolog so here you can see there are two
lines which is of duplicate lines here
right so if we want to eliminate the
duplicates line you just do a unique and
just give this Kiana dolog okay so here
you can say it's eliminated the
duplicate line from here so friends
moving on to the next command that is
cut command Okay cut cut command and
what is the purpose of cut command
suppose if you want a specific column
from a file for example I'm telling c/
Etc pass WD it is the file from here I
only want this users name whatever the
users name like here you can see
subscriber one uhr a ran one or TCP dump
I want only this from this entire uh
file this particular column complete
then how I can use how I can get this
data okay so for that what you need to
do you can use cut command and then you
need to give a delimiter okay and then
so D limiter means what there is almost
colon is there everywhere so you are
using D limiter and which column you
want the First Column you want and from
where you want/ Etc and pass WD enter so
you are only getting a data which is of
first line here you can see clearly so
I'm only getting the username rest of
the data is eliminated so friends moving
on to the next command that is WC
command here only you can come to know
see suppose how many user names are
there just know I get a data but at the
same time if somebody is coming to you
and he's asking how many usern names are
available in this file same just do a
pipe and just do a WC means word count
okay so you will come to know how many
word counts are there but WC can be also
used with hyphen L okay so now you'll
come to know 45 usernames are there okay
directly you can get this data with the
WC WC stands for word my friend okay now
moving on to the next command my friend
that is T command okay so how T command
is used I am going to show show you so
I'm going to use this same command okay
and if I want this data to be redirected
to a file I want this see this is just a
display but if you want this one to be
into a file you just give one here file
1.txt okay Enter now if you do LL over
here so here you can see file 1.txt is
created and if you do cat of this file
all the data is here this is how we can
use T command so friends moving on to
the next command that is alas command so
alas command what it does is suppose
just now we have executed this command
my friend right so I want this command
to be alas means I want this command to
be sorter okay so I don't want to
execute this full command I can't
remember this command all the time so
for that what what you need to do is you
just need to do a alas of this one so
I'm uh making this hold command as a F1
okay here you can see right and if you
do enter over here so the next time I no
need to run I what I need to run I just
need to run my friend here F1 okay so if
I run F1 I'm getting the same output so
ultimately it's creating a shortcut of
your command so friends moving on to the
next command that is alas so just now
you did a alas so same way what you need
to do is just do a un Alas and you need
to give the shortcut of that name enter
now if I run F1 this time it's not going
to give me any output because just now I
I did analias for that one so Friends
next command is Echo command if you want
to print anything in the terminal you
can use Echo command Okay suppose if I
want to print anything for example if
I'm telling here that hello
world okay so it's going to give me the
output as a hello world my friend okay
so friends the next command is slep
command the name itself is clear so if
you want to make sure if you are
executing any command and if you want to
uh give a delay of two seconds or a 3
second then you can use a slip command
let me show you how we can achieve this
one so I'm going to create a file here
called you can give any file over here
I'm just going to give a file called
subscriber two okay and I'm just
creating a script of this one okay so
here I'm going to give this one Ive
created a b script of this one and I
have given a sleep of 2 second and sleep
of 3 seconds so first it it's going to
Echo starting and after 2 seconds it's
going to give for working and after 3
second it's going to give the echo it's
going to print finished over here right
so
and you need to give
permission CH mode executable permission
to this one my friend to execute this
script okay now if I have to execute
this script okay here you can see
starting is giving it's waiting for 2
seconds now it's wait for 3 seconds and
now it's given finished so this is how
we can use slip command so friends
moving on to the next command that is
was command that is if you want to
execute a command repeat suppose if you
want to execute a command every 5
seconds so I'm I want to execute LS
command every 5 seconds so I'm going to
give like watch is here and then hyphen
n and then uh Lis okay so enter so every
you can see every 5 seconds it's going
to watch it's going to repeatedly
execute the same command so it's wait
for 5 seconds again it's watching so
here you can
see the timing now it's change right
here you can see now it is change every
5 seconds it's repeatedly executing that
one you need to understand from here so
the output is same okay so you are not
able to see because the time is changing
over here okay so friends moving on to
the next command that is NC command the
name itself is clear that is netcat
command suppose if you want to see
whether a port is listening or not okay
whether the network connectivity is
correct or not so you can use this uh NC
command same like Nest command is there
so here I'm going to execute so if you
want to see a port is listening or not
for example SSH Port is 22 okay so it's
it's giving you that b to this one and
this address is already in use so it
means it's listening it's SSH we are
using here so uh it's quitting this one
fine so friends moving on to the next
command that is LS off command if you
want to see the list of open files so if
suppose some user is using some file and
he f got to close that and he just
exited from the system okay so those
files will be still open so you can see
with this lsof command so you can see
these many files have been opened so
friends moving on to the next command
that is man command the name itself I
have previously also explained this is
manual page if you want to know any
suppose CP command is there so you want
to know what CP command is stands for
and what all options we can use with the
CP command you can use man command that
so friends moving on to the next command
that is what is command suppose if I'm
telling what is suppose if I want to
know what is cat command stands for so
it's going to give me a s description of
this command so friends moving on to the
next command that is kill command
suppose if you want to kill a process or
a service then you can use kill hyphen 9
is there okay you want to terminate that
process so you remember properly we have
run a command called vsftpd or for
system CTL status vsftpd so you can see
this service is active and running so I
want to kill this process or a service
the other way also you can do it but if
you want to use with the kill command
that also we can do it how we can do
this one my friend so just get the uh P
ID of this uh process and uh PS EF and
then pip gra
vft PD so here you can see this is the
process ID my friend okay just do a kill
and hyph 9 and just give this process ID
now the process is how we come to know
it is uh stopped or not so just run this
one here you can see now the same
process is failed so friend moving on to
the next command uh that is SSH key gen
this is very much important command
suppose if you want to authenticate from
this server to the the server of this IP
you can see here and there is another
server also here so you can see right
this one correct so this is a different
IP uh ho itself you can see here right
so if I want to authenticate if I want
to login from one server to other server
password less you want to do a SSH then
in that scenario you need to generate a
SSH key gen like this here you can see
so SSH key gen hyen RSA enter enter
enter so the here I have created SS key
and password less now what I need to do
is if you go to this directory my friend
just go to this directory okay here just
go to this directory and just do a ll
over here so here you can see there will
be a idore RSA and there will be idore
RSA do Pub is there so what we need to
do is we need to take this idore RSA do
Pub and you you need to implement this
into the other server my my friend in
the other server so friends moving on to
the next command that is your uh uh PV
display command is there or you can say
PVS that is physical volume display so
here I have not created a physical
volume so you are not getting any output
there is other command called uh vgs
that is volume group that is see once
you create a physical volume from there
you can create a volume group and from
there you can create a logical volume
that is LVS so I'm not getting any
output over here so this is something
you can execute wherever the physical
volume is created or a logical volume or
a volume group okay so friends moving on
to the next command that is called NS
lookup NS lookup is used to see to
resolve IP to host and host to IP
suppose if I'm running a command called
uh first let me run this one if config
okay I want to know the host name of
this particular server whether it's
resolving or not IP to host and host to
IP means what NS lookup okay
NS lookup and you just give the IP of
This Server so here you can see it's
clearly telling that the server cannot
find the reason is because there is no
DNS mapping happened for this one so
friends moving on to the next command
and uh I am executing this command from
the First Command LL command that is
long listing so you can list down what
whatever the files or directory inside a
directory with detailed information my
friends so this is how you can use the L
command so friends moving on to the next
command that is tell command you
remember I have explained tail command
but there is something called if you go
to CD where log okay here so here what
will happen I'll tell you uh if you see
there are some logs which is generating
continuously so if you want to see the
running logs so then you can use tell
command and hyphen app app and you can
give message like this so it's going to
give you can see the running logs by
running till app command my friend
moving to the next command my friend
that is very much important if you are
doing some kind of Automation and if you
want to schedule that automation suppose
that script it should run 1:00 a.m. in
the morning then where you are going to
do that one that is called your crown
tab okay and just do l so as of now no
Crown tab is
so once you create a script you can
schedule that script inside this file my
friend or directly you can do a crown
Tab and if you want to edit this file
just do a crown tab hyph e so you can
put your entries over here and you can
schedule the script suppose you want to
take the backup of a server then you can
use Crown tab last but not the least
that is two commands one command is your
shut down command now you know what is
shut down command stands for if I shut
down the system will shut down okay and
there is something called reboot command
if I'll use reboot command this Linux
machine will reboot here okay so friends
I'm ending up the session here only
thank you for watching this video and
for more videos stay tuned to my channel
and please don't forget to like share
and subscribe the channel and press the
Bell icon Jin friends